Don't be shy.
Gentlemen,
heard my nephew.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in
authored by
the chapter of patience, we're at the
25th consecutive narration of the book,
but it's the first narration of the
chapter. It's a narration that is very
multifaceted. It has lots of subjects
that it touches upon and each one of the
sentences in this narration
is considered to be a principle a
foundation
upon which that subject is founded.
Allah subh the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam mentions
Purification is half of Eman.
Alhamdulillah
and alhamdulillah fills the scale.
Subhan Allah. Alhamdulillah
and subhan Allah and alhamdulillah
together fill and occupy all that is
between the heavens and the earth.
Prayer is light
and charity is an evidence and a proof
of true faith
and patience albe it difficult is also a
light
and the Quran is either an argument for
you or against you.
He says in the final sentence, the
conclusion to all of this,
he said, "Everyone
goes out, emerges in the morning and
sells himself.
And some upon selling themselves
actually emancipate themselves
while others upon selling themselves
actually sell themselves into bondage.
What does this mean? This is a
figurative
statement of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. If you imagine
Mecca
specifically
is a place of
commerce, buying and selling. Medina had
three
major marketplaces.
It wasn't things are today where
stores and marketplaces are every which
way. These were places designated where
people would go to that market to buy
and sell and find whatever it is they're
looking for. The equivalent of what we
would see today as a flea market.
And
everyone in the morning when the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam would lead
them in fud the sun would start to come
up. You could see all of the people of
Medina start to emerge from their homes
and head towards these marketplaces.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam gave
them an example of their life in this
world
to what they do every day.
that just as we all emerge from our
homes every day and we go to transact,
we go to make deals with each other. We
go to buy and sell. There are those who
have something to sell. There are those
who are looking for something to buy.
Likewise is an person's entire life. If
you were to imagine your entire life as
one day and if you were to imagine your
entire life all building up to a final
sale
and that buildup
is through everybody's actions, the
little choices that they make, the small
choices that they make. These small
choices are footsteps towards that
marketplace
that upon reaching there, you make that
final sale. But what is it that's for
sale? Your soul, your very soul is what
you're selling.
Some people,
most people
are overpowered by their nature and
impulses and instincts and so they sell
their soul for material riches.
They sell their soul for arrogance. They
sell their soul for dominance. They sell
their soul for fear, cowardice, whatever
it is that drives a person to disobey
Allah most of his life to the point that
his soul is at hazard.
So people sell
and when they sell their soul, if they
have sold it to El and his,
then they have sold themselves into
bondage and they have sold themselves
into destruction
by obedience of aan
and other people sell their soul but
they sell it to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
They sell their soul in order to be
emancipated because
the human being was created as a slave.
That's what we were created for to
serve. We always will have a master. No
matter what you do, no matter how much
you flee and reject the servitude to
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, all you're
doing is selling your servitude to other
than Allah.
Said in his
he said,
for
[Silence]
was Shan.
He said that the people of disobedience
and the people of dis and and
disbelief,
they fled and ran
from the slavery that they were created
for, which is slavery to Allah,
and fell into
the slavery
of the nefs and the slavery to aan. So
no matter what a person does, he will be
a slave to something.
If you choose to bow to no one and
nothing other than Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala, you become a slave to Allah.
This is the highest station any human
being can be given. So much so that even
the best of mankind, Muhammad Abdullah
Sam. Wasam in his finest moments in the
Quran is described as what? Abdullah.
He's described as the slave of Allah.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala. On the night of
receiving the Quran, his finest moments,
Allah describes him as what?
Describes him as his slave. This is the
highest station, highest status a human
being can earn himself is to be a
servant, a slave to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. This is not loneliness. This is
highness in its purest sense. And so if
a person sells himself into Allah's
slavery,
they are now free and emancipated
from the slavery of everyone and
everything else. the greatest of
nobility. However, if a person rejects
that, he will sell himself into the
slavery of someone else or something
else. And that is the lowliest station a
person can hold as a human being. Being
a slave to his sworn enemy. Being a
slave to that which has no power to make
him better or worse. Being a slave to
that which was created to serve him.
So the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam tells us
everyone goes out in the morning, the
morning of his life
and sells himself
and subsequently either frees his own
soul
or
sells his own soul into eternal slavery
and damnation. This narration was
collected by Muslim in his
subhanah
and
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu waala
Well,
a manufactur